23 ans qu'il se bat pour connaître le
nom de l'assassin de sa fille à la cour
d'appel de dijon nice et buzet se
présente entouré des membres de
l'association christelle et de son
avocat il craint que l'audience du jour
devant la chambre de l'instruction
aboutissent à la fermeture du dossier
comme cela avait déjà été le cas une
fois c'est angoissant que ça fait
beaucoup de fois qu'on se bat qu'on se
bat concevoir et puis l'art n'est les
années tournoi surtout et donc j'aurai
bien que quand même qu'on trouve
l'assassin de ma fille le 17 mars 1997
le corps de virginie bluzet est retrouvé
menotté et bâillonné dans la saône à
verdun sur le doubs dans un premier
temps son petit ami est suspecté ils
bénéficient finalement d'un non lieu
puis le dossier classé en 2002 son père
se bat et obtient sa réouverture en 2009
en demandant l'examen de série jusque là
délai fait aujourd'hui son avocat tente
à nouveau de maintenir le dossier actif
nous demandons depuis toujours que la
piste michel fourniret au dos de piste
de criminels en série soit étudiée dans
l'affairé virginie bluzet ou non dion
est ce que tous les adn découvert
récemment et qui ont permis d'élucider
l'affairé estelle mouzin le temps les
sur les
les biens appartenant à michel fourniret
un matelas des coussins puisse être
comparés à l'adn de virginie pour savoir
si la justice accepte de faire ses
recherches
le père de virginie devra encore
attendre pour des questions de forme
la chambre de l'instruction renvoie
l'examen de sa demande au 18 novembre